I want to ask you about the dating side
of things so you mentioned that you know
you get the wisdom from being slightly
older
dating has definitely changed for a
younger generation to some degree in
terms of the method so obviously like
Tinder [__] blew up and now we have
this new period of only fans and
especially where I am based in Asia like
lots of only fans models everywhere you
go
like that is to me that's severely
impacted a male's perception of what a
parent or should be or what a partner
could be so when you find a partner it's
like well this promiscuous girl over
here could have equally been my partner
I want to get your thoughts on like what
you think the impact of like only fans
will be on males perceptions
only fans is a recent phenomenon you
know it's funny you mention online
dating and and Tinder and the phenomenon
of of meeting the opposite sex online
isn't new
um I met my ex-wife on a dating site
called Lavalife and there was dating
sites that were even bigger than that
around the time Plenty of Fish lemon
tonic I think
um you know there's a lot of these
dating sites in the early 2000s that
just came out because the internet came
out it's like you know sex cells so
obviously you know dating and
introduction online seem to seem to be
like where it started to pick up it
wasn't until we had apps on mobile
devices where you just swipe left and
right like Tinder and Bumble that made
things so much easier
um because we like easy we like instant
gratification we like a you know quick
and easy match opportunity to open on
that very quickly so to the point of
only fans again you know this is a
recent a more newer phenomenon that
exists and a lot of women use it today
uh what is only fans is it prostitution
not really because they're generally not
having sex with these guys and let's be
honest these guys that are throwing
money at women to subscribe to their
only fans to get pictures of their
butthole or whatever they're getting
um they're not they're not society's
best right they're not the kind of guys
that these gals want to be with they're
just simps and all they're doing is
they're throwing money at these girls
and they're collecting it and these guys
are doing it under the hopes or the guys
that maybe one day they can meet them or
you know something will happen
um so it's a loser's game from that
perspective now if I'm a guy dating and
I meet a gal and I find out that she has
an only fans
Okay so
here's where the frame part of it you
know comes into play
if I'm going to consider
a gal in my life and let's say it's a
long-term relationship an LTR
I'm going to want to make sure she's in
my frame I'm gonna make sure that she's
not doing anything to compromise the
relationship I want to make sure she's
not doing anything to embarrass me I'm
rich Cooper I wrote the unplugged Alpha
imagine if Society found out that my
girlfriend had an only fans
could you imagine
that would be absurd that would be
ridiculous you know that I would allow
something like that right so I mean if
she hasn't only fans and she likes it
and I'm a single guy let's say
um and I think she's fun or maybe she
becomes a friends with Ben I just
wouldn't take her seriously she's just a
girl selling pictures of her butthole
online promiscuity is rampant out there
and women are indulging and men are
indulging and I don't think that's going
to change it seems like that seems to be
ramping up so the angle that I that I
would personally take is date spin
plates which all that means is just date
multiple women simultaneously not
monogamously and then if I'm open to a
long-term relationship which I think
most guys are then you're essentially
going to let the cream rise to the top
wait for her to come to you and say
Where Do We Stand rich I dig your Vibe I
don't want to share you I want to claim
you you know like the standard sort of
stuff and then that's when you can take
a look at their life and say well I like
you too and I've been having a good time
but I'm not going to take a gal
seriously that goes out to lunch you
know every two weeks with her
ex-boyfriend I'm not going to take a gal
seriously that runs in only fans I'm not
going to take a gal seriously that has
you know 20 000 followers on her public
Instagram and she's continuously posting
pictures of herself in a bikini or low
cut cleavage you're exposing a lot of
skin I'm not interested in that right so
I mean where are you at with this like
is this something that you're taking
seriously like is this your life choice
is this your career to be an only fans
model to be an Instagram influencer
right like is this a real job do you
make money at it you know sort of thing
these are some of the questions that I
would have to ask right and you know
when you're dating out there and you're
dealing with these women I just I mean
generally speaking I don't think that I
could look at a woman that's that's
posted pictures of herself naked online
whether they're paid for or not doesn't
matter to me it's disgusting and women
are valued based on their beauty and
their purity
um a woman that shared her body with a
hundred men is less valuable than a
woman that shared her body with one man
for 12 years because she was in a
long-term relationship you see what I'm
saying so you have to evaluate these
things when you're dealing with women in
your life and be again fastidious about
it and you know decisive about the kind
of women that you're going to deal with
and if you want to have those options if
you want to have the option to say no to
women which most guys don't first
you know he gets all excited and wants
to marry her you know for the most part
but when you have options when you're a
high value guy when you're doing
something else with a life more than
just chasing tail you chase Excellence
then you have the opportunity to say no
thank you and you look you know and then
you just let her go and then you pick
better women and then you choose women
that are choosing you right for men that
are in that let's say top 40 bracket 50
to 40 bracket who don't have that much
choice but also like are not that far
like how did they approach that because
they may feel like they don't have the
confidence to be like Oh I'm gonna have
multiple partners oh I'm gonna say no
because like if some girl who sent me
yeah historically like an average guy
can't have multiple women yeah you know
they never have in the past uh if you
look at men in the past that have run
harems of women like Ishmael the
bloodthirsty is one that I go back to he
was a morale consultant and I think the
Guinness Book of World Records has him
on a known record for having the most
children they don't know the exact
number but apparently it's over a
thousand uh he had multiple wives he had
multiple concubines
um he would have eunuchs he would he
would hire eunuchs he would make men
eunuchs to to guard his Harem of uh
women
um and they were all exclusive with him
and he he would just pound out babies
like that was his thing
if you're going to run multiple women I
mean if you're going to run a harem if
you're going to be polygenous you know
for example you you have to have
something going on in your life like you
have to be a high value guy women will
only share a high value Alpha in fact
women are more apt to share a high value
Alpha than be straddled with a faithful
loser it's why women would rather date a
rich successful doctor that's married
than a broke loser that lives in his
mom's basement with a neckbeard smoking
dubes all day playing video games for a
career they'd rather be with the guy
that's done something else with his life
because he also has pre-selection too
because he's got a wife right this is
how women operate and this is a
uncomfortable truth that bugs a lot of
people you know when I say these things
there's people watching this or hearing
this right now they're they're getting
very upset like visibly upset they don't
like it they want to tune out but you
know what you can be upset about it it
doesn't make it untrue it's factual
why do you think women Chase men with
status
because status is really important to
women right I mean if you go back
through history and you know you set
aside all the modern tropes and lies and
you know stories that we've heard about
prince princess one man one woman you
know sort of thing
women in the past have almost always
shared men right
um we are essentially nomadic
hunter-gatherers and we've lived that
way for a very long time it's I think
it's only in the last six thousand years
in modern history where we've indulged
in things like uh you know cities
communities uh markets
um trade stores of value you know were
considered for millions of years prior
to that we were nomadic country
gatherers and we lived in small tribes
that sort of moved around and the men
would go out and hunt and the women
would sort of you know gather whatever
was around the village and take care of
the the children and that's the way
things have always operated and women
would be shared amongst the highest
value men within that tribe I mean like
even today if you go to the Amazon you
know you go to the Amazon base deep
within you know the woods in the forest
um these tribes that have had no
exposure to Modern culture helicopters
skyscrapers you know things like that
things that are completely foreign to
them that's how they still operate today
right you know they're still modern
version of ancient hunter-gatherers
where women generally share the highest
value Alphas in the tribe it's not
always that way but that seems to be the
common way and like monogamy is very
uncommon in the in the animal kingdom
it's it's it's very very uncommon
um it's only become common in humans
over the last you know several thousand
years
um because it's because it's become
enforced and you've got religion then
you've got marriage all of these things
uh you know that sort of modify and play
on us differently but
we are we are both poligenous and we are
both somewhat monogamish I wouldn't say
monogamy
um exists you know within humans because
true monogamy as it exists in the animal
kingdom look if you look at birds for
example that are monogamous if one of
the birds dies that's it there's no
other bird after that you know they just
live as a widow you know sort of thing
like that's the way that monogamy
operates in the wild but in humans we
like to claim monogamy but we're more
monogamish because we because it's one
person at a time
right it's like you know women that will
date a bunch of guys or be in
relationships you know with a bunch of
guy it's always funny because you know
you know if a gal's been with 20 guys
let's say let's use an easy Light number
like that and then she meets a guy and
then he says to her okay you know I dig
your Vibe sort of thing whatever
and she wants to claim to be monogamous
right you know she wants to be exclusive
with him well she's already shared her
body with 20 other guys how is how is
she monogamous
right I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the
full-length podcast you can find that
over here that clips from if you're new
to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out